and here now to respond is Robert
Driscoll now he was the attorney for the
alleged Russian spy Maria booty know who
is right in the middle of this story
Harmeet Dillon attorney Trump 2020
advisory board member and Terry churchy
former deputy assistant director of
counterterrorism for the FBI all right
Robert I know it's a sensitive subject
but what can you tell us that we already
haven't heard well basically the
timelines right I mean there was a
relationship that started at Freedom
Fest in 2015 and continued right up
until the time she was arrested a few
months before that and so to the extent
I know his story sounds crazy but the
extent of intersects with Maria it's
consistent and can be verified through
her as to what the contacts were with
the government my main concerns her
defense lawyer is you know he's told me
that he gave the government of sculpt
organ information saying at some point
that he you know though he was concerned
about her he concluded she wasn't a spy
concluded she was an honest person doing
what she was trying to do as a student
and conveyed that to the FBI if that's
in the 302 somewhere it should have been
turned over to me too or the interview
memos this is the Brady rule from log
geeks out there wanna be so the Brady
rule requires the prosecutor to give to
the defendants team all exculpatory
information now Byrne is saying that
Peter struck was in the middle of this
and that this went to the highest levels
call me McCabe on down like this is wild
now I've got a full declaration of what
I know I've known Patrick Byrne since I
think our first week in college we were
both same class in college and I've
known Phil I don't keep in touch of them
but to me it's it's these appearances on
television were pretty interesting he's
now kind of disappeared we'll get into
it more later but have you heard
anything back from the government
regarding your client who obviously has
been convicted in the serving time for
her own line to the government I sent a
letter raising this issue and asking for
investigation to Durham Horowitz and the
Office of Professional Responsibility I
got a letter back from the Inspector
General saying that OPR would be
investigating and so the investigation
is with OPR right now to look into
whether there was any Brady material
with
there any other attorney misconduct with
respect to Maria's case does any of this
surprise you I know you've known about
her relationship with Byrne for some
time but does this these other elements
we're gonna get into in a minute
Hillary's name being mentioned by Byrne
saying they were someone might have been
trying to blackmail her or something at
some point is that surprising
yeah it's wild when I first heard the
story and first spoke with Patrick I
mean it's it's really and then Ethan got
the same reaction you know three weeks
ago that everyone else had watching
cable last night thinking to myself this
is this is wild but what always struck
me was this guy you know what he says
about Maria was generally accurate and
and he was I could verify most of it so
I have to take it at least seriously at
least the government should take it
seriously because the part that
intersects with what I know and what I
can prove is generally accurate why did
they break up well I mean I think it was
never that close relationship to begin
with I think that they they had common
interests and they got together a few
times over the years I mean I wouldn't
put it as the love of anyone's life but
I think there was a romantic tale rooms
involved two rooms one room is it one
clear there for sure but again mckible
maybe she was dating someone else
there's complicating factors and yeah
I'm not dr. Phil on that front so all
right Terry Turchi how credible is this
claim though that with all your
experience that the FBI specifically
Comey was the director at the time
directed him to have an ongoing
relationship with someone they believed
was a Russian operative when a gal comes
up here from Russia and says listen I've
been sent here to make contact with you
and we want to take you to Moscow and
want you to speak on Bitcoin and speak
on liberalism you have to report that
and before I know it the men in black
are back in in my life and I I was
trying to encourage her to have a
relationship last summer watching
television and some congressional
hearings I figured out where those
orders came from they gave him a guy
named Peter strong and bill free stabbed
Carl in Mackay
Komi that was who sent the orders Terry
I mean people watching this going what
so the Patrick Byrne had a low level
security clearance he wanted to keep it
that's why he reported to whatever
person at the FBI he reported to about
that his relationship or connection with
Martina but call me mccabe involvement
struck what of this they're rejecting
these notions saying it's all this is
all ridiculous the FBI doesn't work that
way
Terry what's the truth here does the FBI
ever work that way well sure in a
counterintelligence investigation or
case the FBI would certainly reach out
to a former asset and for the purpose of
people's understanding in
counterintelligence referred we've refer
to people his assets rather than
informants and so if they'd used Patrick
Byrne in any capacity before it would
have been it would have made sense to
reach out to her and maybe ask him to
rekindle whatever relationship he had if
they were interested in her which we
know that they were and there were a lot
of other things going on during 2015 and
2016 so they could have also benefited
from the idea that if you have for
example let's just take hypothetically
the Russian Trump investigation if that
was in its early stages and was just a
preliminary inquiry then you can
actually reach out to a current or a
former asset like that whereas you would
have to get special approval in a
preliminary inquiry to reach out to
somebody or to develop a new asset so
they had a lot of reasons that they
might have wanted to use him as far as
the part about director Comey
specifically said something to me or
deputy director McCabe something like
that that may not be exactly what he
meant to convey I would I would think
that and I watched his interview on
television I think he meant to convey
that the agents who were talking to him
had let him know that these are the
people cause so it's all very
interesting it's all very kind of as you
watched it you kind of speck another how
was another character in this ongoing
drama Harmeet and Harman I bought went
to the same college he went to the I
heard this is my Patrick Byrne was I got
a left-field I was
what is this bizarre but it doesn't seem
to me to be out of the realm of
possibility har mate and call me
anything they could do at this point to
stir the pot well absolutely Laura out
of these people some of them are known
to be liars I mean we all I think many
of us believe Comey certainly lied
repeatedly and that's been found and pay
mccabe and struck were fired for that
for lying so out of these characters
although this tale is a wild one you
know i have to say that i'm going to
suspend judgment on that until we hear
more facts but so far as Robert said a
lot of this is lining up certainly from
the point of view of his client the
Brady violations are of a piece of what
we've heard out of these this cast of
characters and failure by these DOJ
officials to turn over the information
that's exculpatory and so I'm prepared
to believe a lot of this I mean some of
the details are a bit hazy and there
been a number of different interviews
with some slightly different facts yeah
but I gotta have a question I have a
question here because it's an it is a
bit of an odd timeline because if struck
and is maybe someone can explain it if
struck and all these guys call me they
didn't want Trump to win and then it
then why we have we're hearing this
stuff about well it was attempt to
blackmail Hillary I got the Robert do
you understand not what Robert I'm gonna
ask Terry this do you get that aspect I
do understand that aspect Laura however
again remember this is a
counterintelligence investigation there
aren't even any 302s for example Counter
Intelligence assets are not reported on
302s
they're simply reported on memos and
what we used to call inserts so they're
not the same kind of they don't have the
same kind of oversight that you would
think is that you would see in the
criminal type feel so who knows and I
mean as Jaime just said there's some
question about all the characters in
this play well I can say nothing about
his interview that bothers me at all I
think it all seems pretty reasonable
yeah well I'm gonna say to three of you
is I hope John Durham in Connecticut the
US Attorney's investigating I hope this
is all part of the bouillabaisse effects
that he's going through because all of
this seems just too bizarre and too
a lot of these explanations I appreciate
it all Thank You panel